what's up gq we are
and today we're going undercover on the
internet
it's actually me
let's go
who are your videos
mazda x is known for having a unique
style open
described as intense or aggressive they
combine elements of medium hip hop
and pops thank you yes i think
it's true i like their major
genre is kind of idiom and hip hop but
we do
some very calm music but this is correct
agree with this
please tell me where you image you'll be
in
15 years i love you so much
[Music]
cats kitties wow
two monster eggs if you could change one
thing in this world
what would it be disaster if you could
do this forever
being singers would you do it if you
could give
one device your past future visions what
would it be
before the 19th i won't go there
you just wanna have that time yeah if
you could do this
whoever are you know our job singer
singer
singer would you do that of course yeah
forever of course no no no
really yeah can i ask why
[Music]
bitcoin
[Applause]
[Music]
getting a crowd going i hope we can see
some of your masterpiece real soon
bloody mosaics
choose more good
try grease and drink some beer
throw some beer on the stage yes that's
it until you get drunk
or just a little bit
70 percent that's almost drunk
okay question were you an ammo as a
teenager
because it seems to be that way
yes of course
who is the most natural
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
back to twitter what instruments do you
want to play
in the future my kisses
sexophone
[Music]
oh
next question who would you
like to collaborate with at the
moment drake
think today won't be answering any
actual questions about the album
anyway guys first thing i must eat in
korea chicken here all chicken chicken
korea and next question
x learned english so well being helped
me
no okay
i don't know keep talking about
in english yeah and then
listen are you so good in english
um when i was young my mother and father
even
to me special billion dollars
in english actually
let's check twitter ask muscle x this is
the best album i have ever heard my
question is how long did it take to make
this
album all about love it's all about
thank you maybe maybe six months
next one tell us an anecdote
about past words what's your favorite
part of going on tour
is
what's your favorite part of going on
tour well
of course foods food
and literally just touring
that's the favorite part just to walking
street
and then shopping what do you love most
about mumbai
their existence wow
well seriously keep
okay that's it we're signing off the
internet
bye